dieser mann hat schon viel staub
aufgewirbelt von ihm stammt der satz wir
sind die 99 prozent mit dem die occupy
wall street -bewegung loszog die
finanzwelt das fürchten zu lehren
dann schrieb er den welt- bestseller
schulden die ersten 5000 jahre und
verfolgt das verschuldung ein
herrschaftsinstrument sei und man
schulden darum längst nicht immer
zurückzahlen muss und jetzt will er in
seinem neuesten buch jeglicher
bürokratie an den pelz so radikal dass
wir diesen anthropologen und anarchisten
als linken geist kennt seinen ohren und
seinen augen nicht traut daytrader
herzlich willkommen bei uns wir feiern
heute den tag der arbeit glaubt man dem
was sie schreiben haben viele leute
heute gar nichts zu feiern nämlich all
jene denen sie eine nutzlose arbeit zu
schreiben welche art von arbeit halten
sie denn für so unnütz dass sie sie mit
dem etwas rabiaten etiketten bullshit
jobs bezeichnet ich kann auf diese
formulierung weil ich ständig leute traf
auf partys wenn sie etwas spannendes tun
als anthropologe zum beispiel und die
leute fragen was machen sie oft wollen
sie es ihnen nicht sagen wo nichts
wirklich gehen ein büro eigentlich mache
ich nichts und das geschieht so oft ich
frage mich wie viele menschen jeden tag
zur arbeit gehen und insgeheim glauben
dass es ihre jobs gar nicht braucht das
letzte wäre natürlich dies gegenüber
ihrem chef zu zu geben wurde öffentlich
darüber zu sprechen
also schrieb ich diesen text niemandem
dir denkt sein job sei richtig wollte
ich sagen dem sei nicht so
ich wollte einzig über jene leute
sprechen die insgeheim davon überzeugt
sind dass ihre eigene arbeit nutzlos
sein
was bedeutet das wo bleibt ihre würde
als arbeitender mensch wenn sie im
geheimen glauben dass sie den ganzen tag
nichts tun
wie hält man das aus ein leben lang also
schrieb ich diesen essay der sich im
internet wie verrückt verbreitete
offenbar gibt es millionen solcher
menschen aber haben sie dann manchmal
nachgebohrt und gefragt was die leute
tun also welche art von jobs rechnen sie
dieser kategorie zu überließ es den
leuten über diese dinge zu sprechen
aber es gibt branchen was offensichtlich
ist die meisten firmen anwälte haben
dieses gefühl dass die welt nicht
schlechter wäre ohne ihre arbeit wenn
sie an telefonverkäufer denken das sind
alles industrien die nur dafür da sind
leute zu beschäftigen wenn andere keine
telefonverkäufer hätten bräuchten sie
auch keine am stärksten ist das aber in
der unternehmens bürokratie aldi manager
im mittleren kader die sagen im
wesentlichen organisiere ich bloß
meetings und schreibe berichte und
andere leute organisieren dann meetings
um diese berichte zu lesen hier
wetteifern darum wer am meisten leute in
seiner abteilung hat von denen keiner
was bewegt die für könnten bloß ich bin
der für die ostküsten visionen
zuständige manager nein diese leute sind
nutzlos es macht keinen unterschied ob
es sie gibt oder nicht
können sie sich vorstellen dass leute
ein bisschen verletzt sind wenn man
sagte ihr macht was so unnützes tun die
leute leid oder sagen sie ich bin der
anthropologe wissenschaftler das muss
ans licht noch einmal wenn jemand denkt
seinen job mache sinn dann glaube ich
dass ich spreche von leuten die das
gefühl haben ihre arbeit sei unnütz
angeregt durch meine text gab es
übrigens eine umfrage in großbritannien
die frage war glauben sie ihre arbeit
trägt etwas zur welt bei 39 prozent der
befragten antworteten nein
stellen sie sich das vor elf prozent
sagten sie seien sich nicht sicher
nur genau die hälfte war überzeugt dass
ihre arbeit nützlich sein
ich sage keine von diesen 50 prozent
doch er glauben soll sein job sei
wichtig oder nicht offensichtlich ist er
es jeder weiß dass selber am besten
aber ich widerspreche auch nicht wenn
einer denkt sein job sei nutzlos
ich möchte hier nicht als schweizerische
minister und patriot da stehen oder
sitzen aber ich habe auch
nachrecherchiert und könnte es ein
kulturelles phänomen sein ich habe dann
statistiken gefunden die sagen in den
usa wirklich nicht mal die hälfte sagt
ich bin zufrieden viele sagen ich bin
unzufrieden ich fand für die schweiz
statistiken die sagen 90 prozent finden
ihren job sinnvoll oder teilweise
sinnvoll könnte sein
wir sprechen hier vor allem über die usa
die erwähnte umfrage wurde in england
durchgeführt
interessant daran ist dass man zwei
fragen gestellt hat die eine reihe ist
ihr job
mögen sie ihn die andere glauben sie
dass ihr job irgendwelche sinnvollen
sozialen auswirkungen hat bewegte etwas
braucht es ihnen dabei war die zahl der
befragten größe die sagten sie hätten
einen erfüllenden job als jene die ihre
arbeit als sinnvoll bezeichnete es gibt
also einen signifikanten anteil von
leuten zwölf oder 13 prozent die glauben
ihr job sei überflüssig und trotzdem für
sich selber viel herausholen darüber
nachzudenken ist wirklich spannend was
ist mit mit polizisten gefängniswärtern
richtung machen die einen push it
schober nicht in den augen des
anarchisten noch einmal sie behaupten
dauernd ich würde den leuten sagen ihr
job wertvoll sei ich höre nur zu was die
leute sagen
fragen sie die polizisten ich würde es
gerne wissen selten hat ein
anthropologisches buchen so
eingeschlagen
die vor fünf jahren ihr buch mulden die
ersten 5000 jahre
was hat sie jetzt dazu gebracht ihren
schafen anthropologen blick auf die
moderne bürokratie zu werfen
das war vor allem eine politische idee
mehr als alles andere
weil in den 60er jahren gab es eine
starke linke kritik an der bürokratie
wenn sie soziale diskussionen nehmen
wenn man schaut worüber die leute in den
60ern gesprochen haben da war dieses
ständige gerede dass sozialdemokratie
kommunismus faschismus alles variationen
vom gleichen sein
diese vermischung von geschäftswelt und
bürokratischer macht mit staatsgewalt
dieser diskurs versandete bei den linken
weil ihr von den rechten übernommen
wurde
wenn sie hören was die amerikanische
rechte über obamacare sagt ist es genau
das gleiche nämlich dass es sowohl
kommunistisch wie faschistisch sein
die rechten haben also sozusagen diese
hippie rhetorik gegen die staatliche
bürokratie übernommen
aber sie vergessen dabei dass bürokratie
gleichzeitig öffentlich wie auch privat
ist heute hat einzig die rechte
der bürokratie kritik sie übernahm
einfach diese abgefälschte kritik der
alten linken version
es ist keine sehr gute kritik aber es
gibt sie während die linke zunehmend das
gefühl hat sie müsse diese formen die
bürokratie verteidigen die sie überhaupt
nicht mag
zudem sind wir in der unguten situation
dass wir dringend eine linke kritik an
der bürokratie brauchen weil bei jeder
art von empörung offenbar stets die
rechte profitiert ist es auch ein
bisschen das buch eine rache an der
amerikanischen gesundheitsbürokratie sie
beschreiben eindrücklich oder zu hören
wie sie für ihre mutter formulare
ausfüllen mussten und das war ziemlich
mühsam es ist auch eine rache an der us
bürokratie das buch amerikaner sind
eigentlich recht gut in bürokratie außer
sie sind haben die amerikanische
bürokratie macht das leben der armen
unerträglich und dass es zunehmend der
fall
aber ich hatte immer das gefühl dass es
amerikaner und peinlich ist so gut zu
sein in bürokratie genau das gegenteil
von großbritannien
dort sind die leute stolz darauf dass
sie darin so schlecht sind aber die
amerikaner auf gewisse weise ist amerika
ein deutsches land das so tut als wäre
es englisch sie sind bürokratisch sehr
effizient verstehen sich selber aber
nicht als bürokratisches land ob schon
sie extrem bürokratisch sind ich habe
also eine art seltsames faible für die
amerikanische bürokratie sie ist recht
leistungsstarke in vielerlei hinsicht
interessant ist aber dass sogar in einer
guten bürokratie die wirklich recht
ordentlich funktioniert ständig
absurditäten und dummheiten produziert
werden zum beispiel einmal haben sie ein
beamter hat ihren namen david ohne frau
geschrieben und dann war es zurück auf
feld 0
ja ja es gibt da die abteilung für
motorfahrzeuge man hat diese kleinen
fehler die einen ständig unterlaufen
diese fehler verzweigen sich und
kreieren größere und immer größere
fehler bis zur kompletten katastrophe
verursacht durch eine nadel die jemand
hat fallen lassen und daraus entsteht
ein erdbeben solches geschieht laufen
was aber wirklich interessant ist
ich begann diese blöden fehler zu machen
und wenn ich zurück schaute wunderte ich
mich bürokratische prozesse führen also
irgendwie dazu dass ich halte mich für
eine einigermaßen intelligente person
dass ich sogar leute die dafür bezahlt
sind den ganzen tag clever zu sein
plötzlich in idioten verwandeln sie
sagen es ist ja kein zufall dass die
bürokratie jetzt zunimmt sie sprechen
sogar von ihren gesetz des
neoliberalismus was ist das eherne
gesetz des liberalismus
ich nannte es eher einen liberalismus
neoliberalismus wäre vielleicht besser
man sagt uns dauernd mit bürokratie sei
den staat gemeint was übrigens nicht der
ursprünglichen idee entspricht
bürokratie sei der start und das
gegenteil vom staat sei der markt wie es
sein die beiden einzigen alternativen
entweder den staatsbürokratie oder der
markt und man kann die bürokratie nur
reduzieren indem man den markt
entfesselt ich habe aber beobachtet und
ich glaube das war schon immer so und
kann belegt werden dass tatsächlich
nicht nur das gegenteil der fall ist
historisch wurden märkte von staaten
geschaffen sondern dass auch jede markt
reform die zum ziel hat bürokratie zu
reduzieren letztlich dazu führt dass es
mehr regulierungen gibt als zuvor
mehr papierkram und mehr bürokraten ich
versuchte eine ausnahme zu finden
thatcher behauptet sie habe die zahl der
bürokraten reduziert in wirklichkeit hat
sie aber die zahlen frisiert
in den meisten fällen stieg die zahl der
bürokraten drastisch das
bemerkenswerteste beispiele sich
gefunden habe war russland ich fand eine
weltrangliste gezeigt dass nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion von 1992
bis 2002 die zahl der beamten um 25
prozent zugenommen hat von einer million
auf 1,25 millionen in einer zeit als die
wirtschaft schrumpfte als sie sich vom
sowjetsystem befreiten und all diese
privaten bürokratien schufen unsere
großen betrieblichen strukturen die in
dieser zahl nicht einmal enthalten sind
die gesamtzahl der administrativen
stellen inklusive privatsektor muss um
die hälfte oder mehr gestiegen sein
ich will nicht sagen dass ich nicht da
manchmal auch nicht nervös zeugs das man
ausfüllen muss und so aber ist es nicht
auch ein bisschen ein klischee vor einem
jahr hatten wir in dieser sendung den
damaligen chef der eu kommission josé
manuel barroso und ich habe ihm auch
gesagt diese eu zum beispiel ist ein
bürokratisches monster worauf er
antwortete die ganze eu verwaltung hat
nicht mehr beamte als die stadt münchen
eine deutsche großstadt
und das stimmt wenn man danach schaut
also und dramatisieren wir das nicht
auch hatten sie harte zahlen die
beweisen dass die bürokratie wie ein
krake da um sich
sie müssen die bürokratie auf zwei
ebenen erfassen
erstens kann man nicht nur von der ampel
sprechen das buch weist darauf hin dass
der unterschied zwischen öffentlicher
und privater bürokratie seit den 70er
jahren weitgehend verschwunden ist die
beiden verschmelzen miteinander wenn sie
mit ihrer bank am telefon sind und in
eine dieser abfindungs strahlen geraten
ich beginne das buch mit einem solchen
beispiel es kostete mich eine stunde am
telefon ein von der bank geschaffenes
sicherheitssystem zu überwinden durch
das mir der zugriff auf mein konto
verweigert wurde schließlich
funktioniert es nicht einmal wenn sie
sich bei einer bank darüber beschweren
heißt es mit all den staatlichen
regulierungen sind uns die hände
gebunden man hat fast keine spielräume
wenn sie schauen wie die gesetze
verabschiedet werden es sind die
interessenvertreter der banken die die
gesetze schreiben und die banken
regulieren
die lobbyisten varel mit den
gesetzgebern und eben input ist es also
eine öffentliche oder einer private
bürokratie es ist fast als gäbe es
keinen unterschied mehr
die beiden durchdringen sich gegenseitig
so sehr dass sie einst werden
wir sprechen also nicht nur von beamten
all diese bank lobbyisten sind ebenfalls
bürokraten die bürokratie ist eine
ständige vermischung von öffentlichen
und privaten elementen das ist die eine
ebene die andere ist zu erfassen wie
viele stunden wir mit papierkram
verbringen sogar wenn sie die
sowjetunion nehmen die klassische
bürokraten gesellschaft die leute damals
haben nicht jeden tag stundenlang
formulare ausgefüllt viele von uns tun
das aber eigentlich mit dem was sie
sagen bestreiten sie eines der großen
gesetze des kapitalismus wie es josef
schumpeter formuliert hat die kreative
zerstörung der innovative unternehmer
lässt neue produkte machen und so
schreitet der kapitalismus voran sie
sagen pustekuchen das stimmt überhaupt
nicht und dann beklagen sie sich im buch
das wir zum beispiel keine fliegenden
autos haben und dass wir noch nicht auf
den mars reisen kann
da muss ich sagen das hat mich
überrascht ein bekennender anarchist
beklagt sich weil wir keine fliegenden
autos haben warum nicht alle anarchisten
glauben es wäre schön eine welt zu haben
ohne staatliche zwänge mit echter
demokratie und gleichberechtigung
es gibt keinen grund weshalb das nicht
mit high-tech zusammengehen soll
tatsächlich glaube ich dass eine solche
welt technologisch weiter wäre aber was
die frieden und autos anbelangt ich
bestreite nicht dass der kapitalismus
nicht auch eine kraft der schöpferischen
zerstörung war es gab zeiten wo die ist
klar der fall war aber heute fragen
sogar viele kapitalisten warum dies mit
der zeit immer weniger so ist und was
mit dem heutigen kapitalismus los ist
geschafft nicht mehr im gleichen tempo
technologische innovationen
wissenschaftliche und technologische
durchbrüche neue energiequellen von der
zeit der industriellen revolution bis
mindestens in die 1950 er jahre
erwarteten wir irgendwie dass sich die
wissenschaft grundlegend verändern würde
das entdeckungen wie genetik kreativität
quantentheorie in regelmäßigen abständen
stattfinden würden
das neue energiequellen und noch nie
dagewesene technologien geben wird wenn
sie science fiction anschauen was die
leute um 1900 gelesen haben wir es 1950
sein wird und ich weiß dass in ihrem
elternhaus viele science fiction büchern
stand sie kommen aus einer
arbeiterfamilie da habt ihr viele
science fiction bücher zu hause ja das
stimmt ich stamme aus einer
arbeiterfamilie aber aus einer radikalen
arbeiterfamilie mit unzähligen büchern
über anthropologie geschichte und
science fiction das ist wirklich ein
punkt es gab kaum kapitalismuskritik
erarbeiteten den ganzen tag da braucht
man kann die bücher um zu wissen warum
was schlecht ist
es ging um realitätsflucht dem versuch
sich etwas anderes vorzustellen seine
vergangenheit an entfernten orten oder
in der zukunft
ich wuchs mit diesem science fiction
zeugs auf aber etwas frustriert mich
ich war 7 98 jahre alt als sie auf dem
mond landen
und wir alle stellten uns vor wie die
welt 2001 oder gar heute aussehen würde
wir haben die bilder und wir hatten eine
vorstellung
es war nicht anzunehmen dass wir alle
spielzeuge von denen gedachten dass sie
kommen erhalten würden aber mit der
hälfte davon rechneten wir schon das
entsprach die historischen erfahrung von
der vorstellung die man sich 1900 über
die welt von 1965 gemacht hatte wurde
etwa die hälfte verwirklicht und raketen
aber keine zeitmaschine also glaubten
wir dass es wieder ähnlich sein würde
die hälfte und haben überhaupt nichts
erhalten
das internet viele denken doch diese
wunder nicht ja aber sogar die computer
damals glaubten sie dass wir computer
haben werden mit denen man sich
unterhalten kann dass wir androide haben
werden die unsere hunde ausführen und
unsere wäsche waschen
stattdessen haben wir diese kleine
spielzeuge und das ist nettes spielzeug
aber nicht mehr was dem post modernismus
anbelangt kam ich zum schluss dass die
ironische repetition die hüter realität
dem sie ein echter aus als in realität
sind aber nicht echt und die nachahmung
von dingen die es gar nicht gibt
irgendwie macht das alles sinn weil wir
in verlegenheit sind weil wir glaubten
dass diese dinge wirklichkeit würden das
nie geschafft und wir schauen eine
dieser schlechten star wars filmen die
spezialeffekte sind großartig der film
ist schrecklich und ich erinnere mich
dass ich dachte wow in den 50er jahren
gab es science fiction filmen mit so
schlechten spezialeffekten die filme
waren zwar gut aber die spezialeffekte
schlecht die leute von damals müssten
von den heutigen spezialeffekten
beeindruckt sein
aber nein sie wären überhaupt nicht
beeindruckt weil sie damals glaubten
dass wir 2008 diese dinge wirklich tun
würden
dass wir tatsächlich auf dem mars sein
würden aber alles was wir erreicht haben
ist dass wir großartige wege gefunden
haben es zu simulieren das war eine art
konzeptioneller durchbruch simulation
hyper realität das ende der geschichte
diese ganzen posten oder einen gefühle
sind eigentlich dafür da die
technologische enttäuschung zu
bewältigen
wir glaubten daran dass wir diese
technologien haben werden und alles was
mir nun haben ist eine technologie mit
der wir all jene erfahren
profitieren können wir können nicht
zugeben dass wir uns betrogen fühlen
weil man dann sagen muss ich war naiv
genug daran zu glauben und dann machen
sich alle lustig über uns deshalb kommen
wir mit dieser postmodernen rhetorik um
mit diesen gefühlen über die wenig
sprechen können fertig zu werden
träumt der amag ist eben auch von einem
stärkeren zugang zum richtigen leben
nicht nur simulation sondern möchten sie
etwas mehr richtig ja genau ich glaube
das ist absolut möglich
es gibt dinge in die geschichte die wir
definitionsgemäß nicht wissen können und
andere von denen wir zumindest annehmen
was hätte geschehen können also ziemlich
sinnlos zu tragen was hätte geschehen
können
wir können nie voraussagen was geschehen
wird aber sobald es eintrifft müssen wir
so tun als wäre es unvermeidbar gewesen
aber es gibt gute gründe zu glauben dass
das ausmaß der kehrtwendung in der
forschung weg von der
raumfahrttechnologie wie sie in den 60er
jahren gefördert wurde
in den usa war es klar dass ein großteil
davon explizit wegen den kalten krieg
gepusht wurde jemand sagt er einmal die
apollo mondlandung sei der größte
historische erfolg des sowjetkommunismus
gewesen ohne den hätten die amerikaner
das nie gemacht aber sobald die sowjets
keine technologische betrogen mir waren
änderte man die ausrichtung der
forschung
das ist sehr deutlich in pink tanks
diskutierten die leute damals in
richtung informationstechnologie
medizinische technologie und natürlich
militärischer forschungen haben die den
kurs gewechselt der kapitalist will doch
dinge produzieren die die leute kaufen
und wenn wir jetzt so raketen rucksäcke
hätten und und und eine marsreise machen
könnten das wirken kaufen
warum hat der kapitalismus
einen anderen weg eingeschlagen es ist
eine interessante frage
eine möglichkeit ist dass sie marx
gelesen haben und zum schluss gekommen
sind dass er recht hatte marx
argumentiert dass der profit kleiner
wird je stärker man eine produktion
roboter riesig dass in den 70er jahren
geschah ist sie begannen die produktion
in den globalen süden auszulagern womit
weniger technologie produziert nehmen
sie die ideen der postmoderne viele
leute stellten sich irgendwie eine
kulturell begleitete neue technologie
vor eine art roboter rieselte
nanotechnologie dinge werden automatisch
produziert arbeiten und verschwinden in
wirklichkeit geschah nichts dergleichen
man begann turnschuhe mit alten singer
nähmaschinen in indonesien zu
produzieren einfachere technologien als
man zuvor benutzt hatte für die
postmoderne empfindlichkeit war das ein
ironischer ausweg um nicht darüber zu
sprechen was wirklich ab ging nämlich
gewissermaßen ein technologischer
rückschritt es gibt also gründe weshalb
einfachere produktionsformen profitabler
sind
das erklärt diese entwicklung sich meine
verkaufen kann man alles ich glaube den
kapitalisten ging es weniger ums
marketing als auch die kontrolle der
arbeitskräfte es gab riesige rebellionen
wilde streiks in den siebziger jahren
liefen verrückte dinge
es macht sinn die produktion von jenen
orten abzuziehen wo die arbeiter am
besten organisiert sind wiederum viele
leute waren wirklich besorgt wegen der
roboter regierung und ihren sozialen
effekte wenn sie bücher wie der zukunfts
schock lesen das glaube ich 71 oder 72
erschienen ist ein großteil der
diskussion drehte sich damals darum dass
alle probleme der 60er jahre durch zwei
schnelle und unkontrollierte
technologiesprünge verursacht wurden
damals war das ein großes thema die
leute sagten denken sie an die hippies
was geschieht wenn maschinen alle arbeit
verrichten die ganze arbeiterklasse so
zu hippies um gottes willen das wird
eine katastrophe
viele leute befürchteten dass die
mutterschaft verschwinden würde dass wir
nur noch retortenbabys haben eine art
sozialer panik vor den auswirkungen der
technik wurde entfacht und wird sie
schauen hoch investiert wurde in der
informationstechnologie medizinisches
zeug und was dabei herauskam prozac
ritalin all diese segnungen zur
kontrolle des verhaltens sie
investierten den technologien die
vermehrte soziale kontrolle ermöglichen
statt die arbeit zu eliminieren kamen
sie mit dieser informations technologie
die dazu führt dass menschen sogar mehr
arbeiten
es ist fast eine verschwörung des
kapitalismus der uns eine
beschäftigungstherapie gibt dass wir
nicht wie bis
marktplatz uns alternative ideen
ausdenken um verschwörung leute brauchen
diesen begriff um jeden gedanken zu
diskreditieren wie er andeutet dass die
herrschende klasse nach bestimmten
regeln funktioniert verschwörung meint
es ist geheim
das ist nicht geheimen sie können das
nachlesen artikeln büchern und think
tanks wird darüber diskutiert das war
allgemein bekannt
ich muss sagen sie haben ein
eindrückliches beispiel hier von einer
fabrik einer teefabrik in frankreich die
illustrierte sie wie das mittlere
management erst unnötige arbeit macht
und dann alles kaputt macht das hat sie
beeindruckt dieses beispiel die tvl die
in der nähe von marseille war es lebten
eine der großen konzerne hatte den
betrieb übernommen
ursprünglich war es eine lokale marke
mit dem namen elefant die arbeiter
hatten den betrieb gesetzt sie erklärten
mir wie sie die maschinen verbessert
hätten über die jahre hätten sie hier
mal was hinzugefügt mal da und so die
produktion um 30 bis 40 prozent
gesteigert
in den 40er 50er und 60er jahren gab es
eine art einverständnis einen deal nach
der idee von kanyes eine soziale
übereinkunft wonach gesteigerte
produktivität mit höheren löhnen belohnt
wurde das verschwand mit den
geschäftsleitungen der 70er und 80er
jahre
diese gewährten den arbeit und trotz
steigender profite keine lohnerhöhung
sie stellten auch nicht mehr arbeiter
ein stattdessen engagierten sie immer
mehr mittleres management und die
arbeiter sagten in dieser fabrik gab es
nur zwei juristen den verbindungsmann
und den chef
und dann gab es uns vielleicht 50
arbeiter plötzlich hatte es nun aber
drei vier fünf sechs sieben dieser typen
in anzügen die herumschlichen und nichts
zu tun hatten
sie gewährten sich wie auf dem laufsteg
schauten den leuten über die schulter
schrieben berichte und allmählich
brauchten sie eine art rechtfertigung
also machten sie einen plan und
beschlossen den ganzen betrieb nach
polen zu verlegen und alle zu feuern
nein die arbeiter besetzten die fabrik
und haben sie alle rausgeschmissen und
seither besteht eine patt situation kann
ich mir schon vorstellen dass
also solche dinge gibt wo dann berater
mittleres management die sache nur
kompliziert ist wiederum ich will kein
super patriot ihr seien aber in der
schweiz arbeiten die meisten
beschäftigten doch in kmu kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen
und sie sagen aber auch in der
privatwirtschaft ist ist total eine
bürokratisierung da stelle ich mir
einfach nur der besitzer der chef oder
die chefin der das ganze unternehmen
gehört die wirken doch nicht
bürokratische leerläufe laufen lassen da
verlieren sie geld das ist ja das
faszinierende genau das hat uns gelehrt
im sowjetsystem hatte man das konzept
der vollbeschäftigung also stellten sie
laufend leute ein die sie eigentlich
nicht brauchten sie schufen dauernd neue
jobs und arbeit und machten dinge
komplizierter um einen vorwand zu haben
mehr leute einzustellen
der kapitalismus gilt als jenes system
wo das nicht geschieht aber egal mit wem
sie in einem großen kapitalistischen
unternehmen sprechen wenn sie mit der
idee kommen dass es letztlich auch
sinnlose beschäftigung gibt erzählt man
ihnen erstaunliche geschichten jedes mal
wenn ich das gemacht habe sagten alle
nein bei uns nicht außer in diesen
bereichen getan
in großen ja ich bin sicher im kleineren
firmen ist es anders aber die aktuell
vorherrschende form des kapitalismus ist
bürokratisch und ich glaube seit den
1970 er jahren hat sich das enorm
verstärkt in großen unternehmen die
immer bürokratisch sind verstand sich
die betriebseigene bürokratie
gewissermaßen als bündnispartner der
arbeiter gegen die finanzinteressen
leute wie grace haben das beschrieben
wenn sie autos herstellen oder papa was
immer sie produzieren
das einzige was alle in diesem betrieb
verbindet ist die interesse an autos
oder papa man wird versuchen mehr und
bessere autos & parts herzustellen
deshalb betrachtet man die finanzleute
immer als außenseiter die sich auf die
eine oder andere art einmischten
das begann sich in den 70er und 80er
jahren zu verändern
einige leute haben das recht gut
dokumentiert vor allem kam es zu einer
viel stärker
ihren bürokratisierung des finanzsektors
zweitens konnte man zwischen der
finanzabteilungen dem management hin und
herwechseln aldi corporate buyer auf die
junk bonds und die verrückten
errungenschaften die in den 80er jahren
aufkamen
im wesentlichen ging es dabei um eine
neuaufstellung der oberen etage der
betriebs bürokratie und der neuerdings
bürokratie vierten finanzabteilung bis
sie miteinander verschmolzen
nun hatte man überall die gleichen typen
leute wechselten hin und zurück sie
heirateten untereinander mit der zeit
gehörten sie zur gleichen sozialen
schicht und man feierte sie für die
anzahl arbeiter die sie entlassen konnte
gleichzeitig wurde jedermann dazu
ermutigt seine rolle die finanz logik zu
unterstellen wenn sie nachrichten
schauen haben sie die börsen meldungen
die unter den news über den bildschirm
laufen weil natürlich jeder die sich
genügend für die welt interessiert um
nachrichten zu schauen vermutlich zur
schicht der investoren gehört oder
zumindest die welt von behren
gesichtspunkt aussehen
nun sie zeichnen in ihrem buch ein sehr
düsteres bild vom staat ein bild das ein
bisschen erinnert an romane wie den
prozess von kafka empfehlen ist das was
die diese café stimmung fast noch besser
aufgenommen worden als im café im film
basiert von terry gilliam der zeigt ja
einen furchterregenden staatsapparat
niemand weiß was der nächste beamte tut
und die erzählt dann die geschichte von
einer braven bürgerin die versucht
herauszufinden wohin er nachbar
verschwunden ist den man fälschlich des
terrorismus bezeichnet die soll man sich
gegen einen solchen staat wären
das ist furchterregend
der nächste
ich möchte eine unrechtmäßige
verhaftungen leben dann müssen sie zur
informations aufpreis stelle
aber da war ich doch schon ich komme
gerade von daher haben michael schick
sie sagten dass sie ein formular das ich
ausfüllen muss haben sie eine verhaftung
squibb er ist die gestempelt nein nein
das ist kein stempel drauf sehen sie ich
kann ihnen das formular nicht geben
bevor das nicht gestimmt und wo kriege
ich das bestimmt informationsausstellung
[Applaus]
die frau wird weiter geschickt zur
informations wieder schaffung behörden
fürchten aber ist dass und das was sie
im buch kritisieren nicht ein bisschen
er das bild des sowjet staates mit dem
überwachungs roboter schlagen sie
vielleicht im buch auch ein gespenst ein
den sowjet apparat nun wenn sie ihren
computer von apple repariert haben
wollen machen sie sehr ähnliche
erfahrungen
das ist eine satire nicht einmal
regierungsbeamte sind so schlimm aber es
ist das gleiche
als ich das buch schrieb hatte ich ein
problem mit meinem bildschirm er musste
ersetzt werden wie kam in den apple
store und sagte ich habe ein problem mit
meinem computer der bildschirm muss
ersetzt werden
ich zeigte ihn und er sagte ja der
bildschirm muss ersetzt werden ich ok
wird ihm ersetzt und er sagte nein sie
brauchen einen termin bei einem der
technischen experten der ihnen
bestätigen kann dass der bildschirm
übersetzt werden muss nein es tut mir
leid diese woche sind sie zu beschäftigt
sie müssen jeden morgen um acht uhr
aufstehen wie sie einen termin kriegen
es ist sie ähnlich außer dass apple ein
privatunternehmen ist außer dass man
nicht im gulag landet wenn man mit der
verwaltung nicht einverstanden ist im
gegensatz zur sowjetunion aber sie haben
dann den liberalen staat auch böse aber
schauen sie mal was passiert wenn sie
versuchen ihre steuern nicht zu bezahlen
ersten polizisten sind beamte in uniform
sie haben wirklich scharfe vorwürfe
gegen unsere kraken mit waffen ja ist
diese scharfe kritik berechtigt glauben
sie wirklich hinter jedem
alltagsphänomen lauert in unseren
staaten die polizei ja natürlich
sie müssen nur irgendwo hingehen wo dies
nicht der fall
ich lebte für einige jahre in madagaskar
an einem ort wo es keine polizisten gab
erst wenn sie an einem solchen ort leben
wird ihnen bewusst wie sehr unser
verhalten tatsächlich vom gesetz
eingeschränkt wird ich begann bücher
über polizei soziologie zu lesen
das sind soziologen die polizisten den
ganzen tag über begleiten mit der
stoppuhr um herauszufinden wofür sie wie
viele minuten aufwenden was die polizei
wirklich tut
rund 50 prozent ist schreibarbeit was
überrascht auch in der zeit in der sie
nicht mit papierkram beschäftigt sind
hat nur ein sehr kleiner teil ihrer
aktivitäten mit kriminalität zu tun
in unserer vorstellung bekämpft die
polizei die kriminalität und bei
kriminalität denken wir an gewalt also
ist die polizei vor allem darum bei
gewalt einzugreifen
das ist aber überhaupt nicht der fall
wenn einer einen anderen schlägt tritt
die polizei normalerweise nicht in
aktion
definitiv in aktion treten sie nur wenn
sich zwei beuteln und einer landet im
spital oder kommt um mit will ich dann
gibt es sei bereit
wie auch immer sie können sich prügeln
ohne dass polizisten einschreiten
versuchen sie aber einmal ohne
nummernschild die straße runter zu
fahren
die polizei wird augenblicklich
aufkreuzen und sie tragen waffen und
wenn sie nicht tun was man ihnen sagt
werden sie angegriffen
das ist was die polizei macht das meiste
was sie tun hat nicht einmal mit
strafsachen zu tun
ein verstoß der vollzug von gesetzen sie
setzten bürokratische regeln um
aber sie bringen gewaltandrohungen in
situationen wo es normalerweise gar
keine gewalt gibt und mit dem rassismus
in winden es arbeitet offensichtlich
wohin das führen könnte viel klarer als
anderswo
so werden etwa menschen getötet weil sie
schwarz zigaretten verkaufen
das ist eine extreme ausweitung der
elementaren logik von polizeiarbeit
extreme extensions dnssec allerdings
gibt es nicht
gerade in großstädten auch in amerika
auch bei uns in europa quartiere war
auch der arche ist david gray war abends
um mitternacht wenn er nach hause geht
irgendwo ist das an der ecke noch ein
polizeiwagen vielleicht steht weil er
sonst überfallen würde oder legen sie
die polizei total ab nun spannend ist
was geschehen würde ohne polizei
offensichtlich haben sie in der
gesellschaft menschen die psychisch
angeschlagen sind die entfremdet sind
die jegliche formen von nihilistischen
rebellionen gegen alles und jedes führen
die frage ist gibt es von natur aus
solche menschen wurde gibt es hier wegen
der sozialen ordnung die nur dank der
polizei möglich ist als anarchist wenn
sie das ansprechen wollen sage ich immer
wie den von der allgemeinen vorstellung
aus dass es ein chaos gebe ohne polizei
würden sich die menschen gegenseitig
umbringen
in wirklichkeit geschieht das nicht
nicht einmal in großen städten in
dänemark glaube ich haben die nazis zu
einem gewissen zeitpunkt die gesamte
polizei verhaftet ein jahr lang gab es
keine polizei die zahl der morde und
vergewaltigungen veränderte sie
überhaupt nicht die eigentumsdelikte
schneiden in die höhe werden wir
professionellen liebe nein das sage ich
nichts ich sage in einer gesellschaft in
der einige viel und andere nichts haben
erstaunt es kaum dass man waffengewalt
braucht um sie zu beschützen und dass
dinge geschehen wenn diese waffengewalt
verschwindet immer nicht interessiert
was für gesellschaft formen möglich
wären wenn man nicht los von der
heutigen situation ausgeht und die
polizei weg nimmt sondern wenn es von
anfang an keine polizei gebe es gibt
einige orte auf der welt die recht
aufschlussreich sind wie ich schon sagte
madagaskar dort wo ich war gab es
irgendwann kürzte die regierung das
budget und zog die polizei aus vielen
ländlichen gebieten ab was zur folge
hatte dass die polizisten verschwanden
nichts veränderte sich die leute machten
fast genauso weiter wie zuvor
von grundstücken man konnte nicht in
großen mengen land worten die nachbarn
raus werfen und sie als arbeiter
anstellen
das verärgerte die leute und man wurde
gezwungen damit aufzuhören aber alles
andere ging mehr oder weniger so weiter
wie zuvor
unsere vorstellung dass sich die
menschen gegenseitig attackieren würden
das ist ein chaos gebe stimmt überhaupt
nicht
also stellt sich die frage was das für
unsere gesellschaft bedeutet die
tatsache dass unser leben darauf basiert
dass bei einem regelverstoß ständig
gewalt droht was macht das psychologisch
mit uns dass wir glauben ohne dieses
system würden wir uns alle wie monster
verhalten das ja nicht stimmt aber es
ist tief verwurzelt in der westlichen
philosophie auch thomas hobbes hat das
kinn sagte der liberale
john locke und sind auch also die von
john bock kam die idee des
gesellschaftsvertrages grundsätzlich
stimmt doch irgendwie plausibel wir
geben das gewaltmonopol den staat dass
er uns schützt und wir uns um unsere
geschäfte kümmern können ist das sowas
historisch hat das gar nicht
stattgefunden trotz hypothese vom natur
start und das hatte sich so vorgestellt
er hat nicht gesagt es sei tatsächlich
so gewesen
dann kam somit der entgegengesetzten
these es war eine art gedankenexperiment
dass auch der verallgemeinerung basiert
wie sich menschen verhalten die sich an
eine bestimmte form von sozialer
übereinkunft gewöhnt haben nun nutzt man
dieses verhalten als rechtfertigung
ähnlich wie meine these im buch schulden
über dem mythos des tauschhandels in
wirklichkeit entsteht tauschhandel wenn
leute die den umgang mit geld gewohnt
sind plötzlich keines mehr haben sie
verhalten sich weiter als ob sie geld
hätten ohne physisch vorhandene wären
wenn man sich nun vorstellt wie geld
erfunden wurde bringt man den
tauschhandel ins spiel
es ist eine zelluläre logik mit der
regierung verhält es sich gleich und
stellen uns vor wie sich leute verhalten
die nie um ihre meinung gefragt wurden
die nie teil einer gemeinschaft waren in
der menschen kollektiv beschlüsse fassen
dieses isolierte egoistische und
individuum das sich daraus entwickelt
wird zeitlich zurück projiziert und man
sagt genau deshalb müsse man diese
institutionen schaffen die aber
letztlich der ursprung dieser
verhaltensweisen sind
ich habe in der einleitung gesagt viele
staunen dass ein linker wie sie so auf
die bürokratie losgeht denn mit diesem
misstrauen sind sie natürlich in
allerbester rechtskonservativer
gesellschaft und ein großmeister dieser
argumentation überall ronald reagan und
bei dem könnte es dann so in dieser
krise bringt der stadt nicht die lösung
des problems
der staat ist das problem das ist auch
ihre these eigentlich er sagt solche
dinge aber er meint es nicht ernst
die anzahl der beamten schnellte unter
regen in die höhe was ist mit einem mann
wie donald trump dem republikanischen
präsidentschaftsbewerber der sagt auch
der sound der die die kommen nicht raus
oder stört sie diese argumentative nähe
zu solchen figuren mit trump oder gar
nicht nein ich glaube diese leute wollen
das nicht im ernst heute die rechten
sagen sie seien gegen den staat
die rechten sagen auch sie seien für die
demokratie was nicht stimmt die rechten
glauben hat die mutterschaft klar diese
klausel schöne sachen
das heißt nicht dass ich jeden
mutterschaft bin nur weil die rechte
dafür sind ich glaube solche leute kann
man nicht ernst nehmen
solche leute kreieren eine verschmelzung
zwischen öffentlicher und privater macht
da drücken sie tatkräftig mit regen
weitete den staat aus indem er banken
und andere institutionen unterstützte
die zuvor bis zu einem gewissen grad
autonom waren im wesentlichen erreichte
er eine verschmelzung von staaten
und unternehmerischer macht wie es sie
zuvor nie gegeben hatte und er benutzte
die ganze amt die regierungsrhetorik um
dies zu rechtfertigen aber das ist total
unehrlich wenn solche leute über der
regulierung sprechen meinen sie nicht
wirklich der regulierung für sie ist es
ein absolut nichtssagender begriff in
der regel eher sprach man auch von der
deregulierung des bankensektors der
telekommunikation und der
fluggesellschaften bei der
telekommunikation und den
fluggesellschaften bedeutete der
regulierung dass man die gelenkte
konkurrenz zwischen wenigen kleinen
firmen in eine breitere konkurrenz
zwischen mittleren betrieben verwandelte
beim bankensektor hingegen wurde aus der
konkurrenz zwischen mittleren betrieben
mit der deregulierung eine gelenkte
konkurrenz zwischen wenigen großen
firmen
man meint in den beiden fällen also
genau das gegenteil
das einzige was die regulierung bedeutet
es gibt keine deregulierten banken das
ist absurd
diese dinge sind gezwungenermaßen
reguliert die regulierungen ginge nicht
zurück wenn man die zahlen anschauen
würde nahm sie zu der regulierung heißt
man verändert die regulierungs struktur
so dass die leute die ich mag davon
profitieren
sie sagen also diese rechtspopulisten
die rechtskonservativen die reden nur
vom staat abbauen machen es nicht dann
bleiben die anarchisten die den
wirklichen staatsaufbau machen würden
kann nicht auch sagen gerade mit dem new
deal und roosevelt den 1930 er jahren
und so hat der staat aber auch viel
gutes auch den bescheidenen einfachen
leuten gebracht einen job lebenslang wo
sie dezent leben konnten oder ist jeder
stand schlecht starten sind im grunde
genommen monopole von gewalt ich glaube
nicht dass was staaten tun
diese bestehen ja zwangsläufig aus
menschen viele meinen ist gut und vieles
was sie tun könnte genauso gut ohne die
elemente von zwang und gewalt umgesetzt
werden
interessant ist aber wenn sie sich zb
die geschichte des sozialstaats
schauen im buch verfolge ich einige
dieser entwicklungen ich gehe zurück auf
bismarck und solche leute in deutschland
kennen sie im neunzehnten jahrhundert
die entstehung praktisch all dieser
einrichtung beobachten die wir heute als
grundlegende institutionen des
sozialstaats verstehen
geschaffen wurden sie aber außerhalb des
staates alles von
gesundheitseinrichtungen über
sozialversicherungen bis zu öffentlichen
bibliotheken alle einrichtungen dieser
art wurden von gewerkschaften
nachbarschaftsgruppen kooperativen
arbeiter vereinigungen von freiwilligen
gruppen ins leben gerufen
die meisten davon waren sozialistisch
manche auch anarchistisch im allgemeinen
war ihre ausrichten er links sie waren
demokratisch und weitgehend selbst
verwaltet bismarck erklärte viele davon
für illegal
er verbot die sozialistische partei sie
hatte panische angst vor einer neuen
pariser kommune in deutschland
gleichzeitig versuchte er ihr programm
zu übernehmen er sagte okay wir geben
euch eine sozialversicherung wir geben
euch die bibliotheken ihr könnt das
alles haben aber ihr dürft es nicht
selber betreiben wir organisieren das
als modell diente ihm die deutsche post
die unglaublich effizient warnte jeder
mochte er sagte wir machen es lieber die
post und das wird großartig sein
wir werden die effizienz steigern indem
wir zentralisieren
so nahm mit den leuten die kontrolle aus
den händen seinen freunden gegenüber war
ehrlich im prinzip ist es eine
bestechung der arbeiterklasse damit die
nicht kommunist zu werden und uns alle
umbringen
das war die idee dahinter und dieses
modell funktionierte unter bismarck so
gut dass sich alle davon inspirieren
ließen sogar lehning der sagte wissen
sie für die sowjetunion stelle ich mir
so etwas wie die deutsche post vor aus
dem sich der sowjets staat entwickelt
was schließlich bringt war das post
modell aus diesen staatlichen top-down
bürokratie modell entwickelte sich was
man heute unter sozialstaat versteht das
war aber nicht die ursprüngliche idee
sollte nur um den sozialismus und
kommunismus sich von leighton es hat
doch den menschen über lange jahrzehnte
viel gutes gebracht
ich weiß nicht sind ihr elternhaus ihre
beste bildungsmöglichkeiten auch für
working class familien und so der hat
auch gutes gebracht dieser sozialstaat
oder nicht absolut das waren erfolge von
volks kennen zum sozialen kompromiss
gehört dass wir uns damit einverstanden
erklären mussten die verwaltung dieser
errungenschaften dem staat zu überlassen
das heißt aber nicht dass der staat es
aus herzensgüte gegeben hat und das
heißt auch nicht dass nur der staat
diese dinge organisieren kann ich meine
was der staat uns gegeben hat kann er
uns auch wieder wegnehmen
und genau das ist geschehen sobald man
die kontrolle art gibt dann sagen sie
sie müssen das budget kürzen und so
weiter und plötzlich nehmen sie alles
wieder weg was wir jetzt überall
beobachten können erhalten kann man
diese errungenschaften nur wenn man sie
vom staat trend und auch von den
strukturen der gewalt das ist die
eigentliche botschaft meines buches wenn
sie über anarchismus sprechen wollen
aber es ist kein anarchistisches buch
ich schreibe darin nicht direkt über
anarchismus aber wenn sie darüber
sprechen wollen die leute sagen
wie können sie über ein nationales
gesundheitssystem sprechen und
gleichzeitig anarchist seien in
großbritannien denken viele leute über
solche dinge nach ich habe darauf eine
einfache antwort es gibt institutionen
die von unpersönlichen strukturen
geleitet werden bürokratien wenn sie so
wollen die auch bestehen könnten ohne
dass es jemanden mit stock oder gewehr
braucht der in letzter instanz kommt und
sagt schwaig und mach was man ihr sagt
und dann gibt es solche wo das nicht
geht
die wissen nicht unbedingt weil sie alle
vom staat betrieben werden unsere
erfahrung beschränkt sich auf
institutionen die sich letztlich auf
gewalt stützen
aber jede organisatorische struktur die
ohne gewalt funktioniert wo leute
gemeinsam etwas erarbeiten und jeder
weiß dass man niemanden anrufen kann wir
dann mit einer waffe auftaucht und sagt
mir ist egal was du denkst schwaig und
macht was man dir sagt jede organisation
die ohne das funktioniert kommt
mit anarchismus gut zurecht könnte eine
anarchistische organisation sein
anarchismus heißt nicht dass es an
organisation fehlt und er beschränkt
sich nicht auf eine bestimmte
organisationsform ausgeschlossen sind
einzig organisationen deren existenz auf
gewalt wird und würden sie sagen ihre
arbeit und ihr studium als anthropologe
zeigt wo andere möglichkeiten lägen wie
menschliche gemeinschaften sich
engagieren können sich als anthropologe
weiß ich nicht nur dass all die mädchen
die wir in unseren köpfen haben und dass
wir ohne polizei in das von hawkes
beschriebene chaos fallen würden wir
wissen dass das nicht stimmt weil es
wiederholt nicht eingetroffen ist wir
kennen auch verschiedene arten unsere
wirtschaft zu organisieren es kann
unterschiedliche politische systeme und
kann die welt als ein riesiges
experimentierfeld verstehen dass ich im
laufe der zeit gebildet hat wir machen
uns vor dass das alles nichts zählt das
waren pro meeting wird das war früher
einmal jetzt sind wir high tech und
alles ist anders
bei genauerem nachdenken ein
eigenartiges argument man sagte uns die
technologie würde unsere möglichkeiten
erweitern
als man getreide im ochsen karren
transportierte soll es 57 formen des
wirtschaftens gegeben haben und jetzt wo
wir computer haben nur eine das scheint
mir unwahrscheinlich
warum folgen nicht mehr menschen dem ruf
lasst uns den staat abschaffen wenn man
doch mehr freiheit gewinnen kann warum
ist es so schwierig die leute für den
widerstand gegen den staat dann zu
gewinnen ich glaube in der vorstellung
der menschen gab es eine art krieg vor
allem seit den 1960 er jahren der
sechzigerjahre jagten den leuten angst
ein
viele die heute an der macht sind waren
damals im college jetzt sind sie
erfahrene politiker damals wurde ihre
befindlichkeit geprägt die meisten leute
waren keine aktivisten in den 60ern wir
vergessen das aber jede fühlte irgendwie
dass sich viel bewegt nun all diese
leute die damals nicht aktiv waren
nun am steuer sind fürchten eine
wiederholung von ereignissen die damals
für mich als amerikaner ist klar dass
praktisch alles was die usa in bezug auf
internationale kriege und interventionen
unternommen haben rund um die angst vor
einer neuen vietnam friedensbewegung
konzipiert worden ist das schlimmste
muss irgendwie protest sicher sein davon
sind sie besessen
sie haben dieses präventive verhalten
mir wurde das kurz nach nine eleven
bewusst in washington war ein anti iwf
protest geplant nur einen monat nach den
twin towers
wir überlegten ob wir ihn absagen
sollten und dachten schließlich doch
vielleicht sollten wir es machen einfach
für uns selbst als anarchist in idaho
muss man sich im moment sehr isoliert
und verängstigt fühlen
vielleicht sollten wir uns treffen
einfach sie unser eigenes wohlbefinden
also demonstrierten wir äußerst
friedlich und die bullen es hat tausende
von bullen fünfmal mehr als wäre sie
packten uns gleich neben ihm selbst
banker heute das ganz aus glas ist
normalerweise hätten sie uns dort nicht
in die nähe gelassen sie fürchten uns
zwei stunden lang ein und sagten kommt
schon recht durch das hat mir nicht im
sinn und sagten wir warten einfach es
war demoralisierend furchtbar
sie wollten nach hause fühlen uns
schlecht dann sprach ich mit jemandem
der an den meetings war es geht um den
iwf und die weltbank zwei der
mächtigsten institutionen der welt
er sagte es war schrecklich es gab 47
checkpoints die polizisten schlossen die
hälfte der treffen alle zeremonien
wurden abgesagt alle partys und ich
dachte wow hier feiern einige der
mächtigsten leute der welt ihre
großartige rituelle feier und die
polizei ruiniert ihre partie nur um 1000
anarchisten einen richtig schlechten tag
zu bereiten
stellen sie sich das vor sie müssen
denken wir seien äußerst wichtig die
halten uns für wichtiger als wir selber
wie vor haben die angst vielleicht auf
die haben vielleicht ein bisschen angst
davor dass der große anthropologie david
weber nicht nur aus anthropologie
alternative modelle ableitet sondern
auch schon mal mit dem schwarzen block
und vermummt mit läuft und ein stein
wirft ist das nicht
[Musik]
wir haben keine steine geworfen aber
vermummt da gehen sie ich war an der
organisation von occupy beteiligt ich
glaube da war weniger gewalt im sinn von
es gab keine gewalt gegen menschen oder
doch warum brüllen von unserer seite gab
es keine gewalt gegen menschen
es gab aber auch weniger gewalt gegen
fensterscheiben als während einem
bescheiden die harten hockey spielt in
kanada die zerstören mehr scheiben als
3000 leute von occupy drei monaten
zerschlagen haben
in diesem zusammenhang von gewalt zu
sprechen ist absolut kann es nicht
kippen gewalt gegen sachen deutschen
terrorismus hatte so angefangen dann
gewalt gegen leute und so ist ja kein
schlechtes gefühl wenn steine geworfen
werden ich glaube diese leute haben
einen sehr strikten ethischen code
gerade für anarchisten spiel tätig eine
wichtige rolle weil wir nicht glauben
dass der zweck die mittel heiligt
das ist ein grundprinzip über die
selbstverteidigung gibt es
unterschiedliche vorstellungen darüber
was man tun darf wenn sie oder jemand
den sie lieben angegriffen wird aber man
geht nicht auf leute los und verletzt
sie um politische ziele zu erreichen
ich glaube da gibt es eine sehr breite
zustimmung unter den menschen die ich
kenne
dass wir nicht auf das gleiche niveau
hin absinken wie unsere gegner
wir wissen wohin das führt sie schreiben
aber im buch selber irgendwo ist dieses
bedürfnis nach regeln auch in uns allen
drin und sie sagen freiheit ist die
spannung zwischen dem freien spielen der
menschlichen kreativität kreativität und
den regeln die wir brauchen damit so ein
spiel überhaupt spaß macht sind eine der
leitfiguren von occupy wir sind da
hatten sie auch plötzlich ein bisschen
das bedürfnis nach regen was machen sie
wenn der spielverderber kommt wenn einer
kommt und sagt ich wäre für alles über
den haben muss man sich nicht irgendwie
oder es gibt eine eine tyrannei der
struktur losigkeit schreiben sie sogar
selber
das fehlen von strukturen kann in der
tat tyrannisch sein
einer der berühmtesten texter zustand
aus der feministischen bewegung von jay
freeman die tyrannei in strukturen
weisen gruppen
ich finde der text oder sehr oft
missverstanden heute heißt es oft wenn
wir keine strukturen haben wird alles
von klicks dominiert deshalb müssen wir
transparente strukturen schaffen für die
behörden sie aber sagt etwas ganz
anderes sie sagt dass es für wirklich
egalitäre entscheidungsprozesse
formellen mechanismen brauche in
gewisser hinsicht basieren alle prozesse
die sowohl aus der feministischen
bewegung wie aus dem anarchismus und der
antiautoritären bewegung hervorgegangen
sind auf diese herausforderung wir
brauchen dafür heute dem begriff
horizontal ismus wir sind nicht gegen
regeln und organisationen wir sind gegen
die art und weise wie diese durchgesetzt
werden
wie erwähnt dass einer sagt mir ist egal
was du denkst halt den mund und macht
was man dir sagt sonst schlag richtig
wenn man eine organisationsform findet
die ohne das aus kommt ist das in
ordnung und sie können alle regeln haben
die sie wollen
aber natürlich müssen diese regeln
laufend ausgehandelt werden wenn sie die
regeln ersticken finden können sie sie
kollektiv umformulieren um das geht es
bei konsensfindung prozessen und solchen
dingen
es wurde viel in praktischer arbeit
investiert wo man aus zu finden wie man
50 leute in einem raum dazu bringt
kollektiv einen entscheid zu fällen
entweder zwingt man einer minderheit
beschlüsse auf die sie nicht mag oder
man manipuliert leute dinge zu tun die
sie eigentlich nicht wollen
unmengen an kreativer energie wurden in
die frage gesteckt wie das funktionieren
könnte
aktuell haben wir keine freie
gesellschaft aber wir können
institutionen schaffen die in einer
freien gesellschaft bestehen könnten
wie hat es in der praxis nicht oft
ziemlich knifflig irgendwo beschreiben
sie plötzlich hatten sie 800.000 dollar
spenden geld für okay wenn man wollte
nicht seiner bank gehen weil die bank
böse ist und dann hatte man es in einem
abfallsack das wird ein problem wohin
mit dem geld nur schon das war nicht
weil die bank böse war der grund weshalb
wir das geld nicht auf die bank brachten
war dass sie dafür eine einzelperson
brauchen auf ihren namen
das konto lautet oder sie müssen sich
als non-profit-organisation eintragen
sobald sie mit dem formellen sektor
geschäften setzt das eine gewisse
organisationsform voraus die genau die
art von organisationen entspricht die
wir meiden wollten deshalb gehen wir
nicht zur bank das gleiche geschieht
wenn sie ein auto haben ein informelles
demokratisches netzwerk kann kein auto
besitzen geschenk wieder zerstört haben
die anregungen und ja schließlich
zerstörten wir das auto aber nicht weil
wir den betrieb des autos nicht hätten
organisieren können
wie organisieren alles mögliche dinge
betreiben ist okay für uns
das problem ist wie mit diesem großen
schweren objekt wenn sie damit die
straße runter fahren tauchen wieder
diese typen mit den gewehren offen sagen
bringt mich zu eurem führer und wenn du
keinen führer hast du sie dir was
schlechtes an sie beschlagnahmen das
auto man kommt ins gefängnis
dadurch erscheint es unrealistisch aber
solche organisationen würden bestens
funktionieren wenn geben sie uns ein
haus und lassen sie uns einfach in ruhe
wir finden selber heraus wie man an
gebäude betreibt das geschieht laufend
geben sie uns ein auto und lassen sie
uns machen das problem ist dass sie uns
nicht in ruhe lassen
sie folgen ja eigentlich in dem was sie
sagen auch diesen spruch den die 68
jahren mauern gesprengt hatten zwei
rallyes tom tailor posible wenn man
realistisch ist muss man das unmögliche
versuchen sind hier optimistisch was ist
geworden aus diesen großen hoffnungen
von occupy wallstreet ist das nicht ein
bisschen ermüdet und der schlafdauer ist
das noch voll da wir waren sehr
frustriert über die reaktionen unserer
verbündeten
ich glaube die große fehleinschätzung
von occupy war dass wir glaubten die
mainstream linke die linken
demokratischen parteien sei genauso
intelligent wie die mainstream rechte
was ihre langfristigen strategischen
interessen anbelangt die mainstream
rechten in den usa halten all dieser ab
aktivisten und bürger wir typen für
spinner aber sie wissen dass sie für sie
wichtig sind weil es ihnen ermöglicht
einige dinge aufs tapet zu bringen
wir glaubten die linke würde sich gleich
verhalten dass sie sagen okay wir mögen
diese occupy typen nicht wirklich und
sie uns auch nicht aber wir wollen dass
sie auf der straße sind so dass wir
sagen können wir sind nicht wie diese
spinner
wir sind die gemäßigte alternative davon
gehen wir aus dass man seine verbündeten
in politischen themen nicht verraten
kann indem man sich schon bei
grundsätzlichen dingen hintergeht sie
habe gingen davon aus dass wir uns wie
die tea party in den politischen prozess
integrieren würden dass wir ihre
kampagnen unterstützen und aldi grass
root arbeit machen würden die sie selber
nicht schafften
sobald sie herausfanden dass wir das
nicht tun würden kamen die bullen und
warfen es raus jetzt können sie in den
usa den öffentlichen raum nicht mehr
besetzen
im wesentlichen setzen sie den ersten
zusatzartikel unserer verfassung außer
kraft dort steht schwarz auf weiß der
kongress darf kein gesetz verabschieden
das die pressefreiheit redefreiheit
wurde die versammlungsfreiheit
einschränkt
wenn sie die bullen fragen müssen ob sie
etwas schreiben oder drucken dürfen
bedeutet dass man hat keine redefreiheit
sie sagen natürlich haben wir
versammlungsfreiheit man muss man zuerst
die bullen fragen
die hoffnung bleibt die leute vergessen
dass wir in einer gesellschaft leben die
auf sofortige befriedigung aus ist man
drückt auf einen knopf und erwartet eine
sofortige reaktion
politik funktioniert anders und speziell
soziale bewegungen funktionieren anders
wenn sie das grundlegende
selbstverständnis der menschen verändern
wollen braucht es zeit
auch in der vergangenheit ist es nie
wenn einer auf die straße gehen
daran habe ich noch nie gedacht aber sie
haben recht lasst uns sofort alle
gesetze ändern
nein es braucht zehn zwanzig jahre
insbesondere wenn man versucht wirklich
fundamentales zu verändern wie die
abschaffung der sklaverei oder der
feminismus das braucht viel zeit
manche leute sagen hatte
und hab nichts erreicht ihr seid
offenbar gescheitert nein das ist
lächerlich wir haben in drei monaten
mehr erreicht als sonst jemand aber dann
folgt der lange prozess dort sind wir
jetzt wenn sie näher hinschauen überall
wo es eine wirklich starke occupy
bewegung gibt entstand eine politische
partei die unsere positionen
aufgegriffen hat wenn sie an janis
anders denken sie haben kopien podemos
und zerrissen
ich bin nicht zwingend mit allem
einverstanden was diese parteien
vertreten
aber alle themen die wir aufgegriffen
haben sind plötzlich teil dem mainstream
diskussion
das ist kein zufall es braucht geduld
herzlichen dank so radikal wie david
gruber ist mein gast am nächsten sonntag
nicht ihres bohnet die schweizer
verhaltensökonomen die es in harvard
ganz nach oben geschafft hat sitzt sogar
im verwaltungsrat der credit suisse aber
die wirtschaftswelt ändern das will sie
auch nämlich so dass dort nicht die
männer allein gemacht haben und sie weiß
auch wie es mit einer besseren macht
balance klappt in der sternstunde musik
sehen sie nun gleich ein porträt von
pepe lienhard schönen sonntag
[Musik]